wednesday pft pm franchise tag deadline
day has come and gone and the biggest
name
obviously quarterback dak prescott of
the dallas cowboys no deal done which
means he can
only play under a one-year contract he's
already signed his franchise tender 31.4
million that's what he'll make this year
next year they'll do it all over again
they can't do a long-term deal until the
2020 regular season ends hopefully there
is one and then at that point the
cowboys will have to decide do we sign
into a long-term deal do we franchise
tag him again
or do we let him walk away as a free
agent now the transition tag next year
probably not an option for the cowboys
because either way he gets a 20 increase
over that 31.4 million dollar franchise
tag salary for this year it's
37.68 transition tag or franchise tag
for next year so if they're going to do
one or the other it's presumably the
franchise tag there are people out there
who are speculating the cowboys won't
tag back again next year
that no one will pay him 37.68 million
basically he should have taken the best
deal he could have gotten with the
cowboys now here's the problem with that
thinking
the cowboys chose the highest possible
level of the franchise tag this year for
dak prescott they've already made it
clear that they believe in dak prescott
unless they would be willing to admit
that they regret
using the highest level of the franchise
tag to keep that prescott around to
prevent him from even talking to another
team to completely slam the door on the
possibility of someone signing into an
offer sheet with two first-round picks
as compensation unless
they would say they were wrong to do
that then it's a no-brainer 37.68
million becomes what he gets next year
barring a catastrophic injury or a
dramatic decrease in his skills and
abilities 69.08 million over the next
two years and then
45 million
plus under the transition tag in 2022 or
54 million plus
in 2022 under the franchise tag or walk
away as a free agent like kirk cousins
did a couple of years ago that's what
the future holds for dak prescott it's
that simple in the immediate future he
gets a raise from 2 million in football
salary in 2019 to 31.4 million in 2020.
that is not a bad increase
as increases go
anytime the increase is in the hundreds
of percents
or as the case may be
thousands of percents
that's a pretty good raise over what you
made last year so a 29.4 million dollar
bump for dak prescott to do the same job
that he did
last year now
it wasn't likely that many of the guys
who were franchise tagged were going to
get long-term deals done given the
pandemic given the uncertainty what's
the salary cap going to be next year etc
two deals were done we talked about
chris jones yesterday the chief's
defensive lineman has his long-term deal
and now at a time when it wasn't
expected that derek henry the titans
running back would have a long-term deal
to stay in tennessee he has a four-year
contract reportedly a 50 million dollar
deal with 20. 5.5 million guaranteed and
remember when we hear that guaranteed
just generically guaranteed that means
injury guarantee not full guarantee the
question will be whether or not the full
guarantee is more than i'm checking my
math here
22.61 million dollars because 22.61
million is what henry would have made
this year and next year under the
franchise tag now maybe the full
guarantee will be less than that because
you're a running back there's no
guarantee that you're going to be
healthy enough and effective enough to
get tagged again next year at a 12
million dollar plus number but that's
what essentially you look at from the
standpoint of the calculation this
year's franchise tag next year's
franchise tag how much does the full
guarantee compare to that sum and again
the sum is 22.61
the full guarantee injury guarantee is
25.5 for derrick henry and he's got two
more years where he's committed year to
year
with the tennessee titans and good for
him it's only a four-year deal remember
the back end of these long-term deals
that's just a favor to the team that's a
gift to the team where it has a year to
year option if the player is still
playing well we're happy to pay it if
he's not playing well we tear it up
there's no real upside for the player
under that scenario the shorter the deal
the better three-year deal would have
been ideal for
derek henry four years a nice middle
ground between three and five assuming
that's what the two sides were angling
to get so bottom line is he's under
contract will be to tighten this year
undoubtedly a titan next year and then
2022 2023 we'll see depending upon how
effective he continues to be because
this is a physical running back who
takes a pounding and gives a pounding
and you have to wonder how many years he
can continue to do that at a high level
justifying the kind of salary that he'll
be getting on average over the next four
seasons
two guys who did not get long-term deals
who have yet to sign their franchise
tenders bengals receiver aj greene
and jaguar's defensive end yannick and
gakway now within gakwe he's shown that
he's willing to accept the trade without
a new contract the question is who would
trade for him knowing that they're only
getting a one-year deal remember last
year the seahawks traded for judaevian
clowning after the franchise tag
long-term contract deadline passed
actually the trade happened right around
labor day weekend but
the
texans ended up paying a large chunk of
that money that was due to clowny last
year in order to facilitate the trade
the jaguars aren't going to pay anything
to facilitate a trade of yannick and
gawkway and the problem is whatever the
jaguars want
foreign before july 15 with the
understanding that the team that gets
him signed into a long-term deal with
the team that gets him now not having
any opportunity until after the season
to sign the long-term contract he's
worth less in trade that doesn't mean he
won't be traded but it's a dynamic that
needs to be completely reconsidered and
recalibrated by the jaguars and the key
for the jaguars is this they dump his
salary if they can trade him and as we
are looking at a 2020 season where money
will be down
where there's no indication that the
players will be giving back any salary
the easy way to save money is to take
one of these big ticket items like a
franchise tag salary and move it off the
roster for the jaguars the easy way to
do it take the best deal you can get and
trade yannick and gawkway you would save
a lot of money in the process if there's
a team that's out there that is willing
to give up something of value for ngakue
and take on his franchise tag knowing
that they'd have to give him a 20
raise next year get him signed to a
long-term contract or see him walk away
in free agency as it relates to aj green
something we talked about earlier in the
week the possibility that a team will
just rescind the franchise tender it's
only happened three times in the past 20
years jeremiah trotter then with
washington had the actually then with
philadelphia had the tender vicinity
signed a big contract with washington
cory simon also with philadelphia a
couple of years later had the franchise
tag rescinded in september josh norman
with the panthers at the time had the
franchise tender rescinded and signed
with washington after that franchise tag
went away it doesn't happen often but
when you consider the dynamics when you
consider the financials of the 2020
season it's a great way for the bengals
to save a lot of money quickly and aj
green would walk away and become a free
agent someone would presumably sign him
and he probably wouldn't get
what he would otherwise make from the
bengals this year if they would rescind
the franchise tender but they would save
significant money and as we look at the
financial realities again for the 2020
season they're going to be some teams
that are clamoring for opportunities to
reduce payroll
and when you consider green didn't even
play at all last year what are they
really missing they're saving money
and the team's not going to be any
different than it was last year because
they didn't have aj green on the field
at all in 2019.
one of the
bigger realities that relates to the
ongoing discussions between the nfl and
the nfl players association is the
financial aspect of what will happen
this year next year and beyond given the
lost money as a result of the pandemic
but also the safety protocols need to be
negotiated between the league and the
union there was a report today from
daniel kaplan of the athletic that nfl
owners have scheduled a meeting for
friday and that's basically the drop
dead day if you want to proceed as
scheduled with
rookies reporting
for their covet 19 tests with rookie
conditioning with veterans who are
rehabbing injuries showing up a few days
early for their coven 19 test and then
starting conditioning a couple of days
early and ultimately culminating in
veterans showing up on the 26th not
injured veterans healthy veterans on the
26th and full camps starting on the 28th
friday is the day they have to get
something done unless they start bumping
deadlines back and with the owners set
to meet what that means is the league
expects there's going to be a proposal
on which the owners will vote a proposal
as to
the rules for safety
and other related protocols in the
facility on the sidelines on the bus on
the plane everywhere all of the
comprehensive rules regarding how
football in a pandemic will work plus
whatever financial deal the nfl and the
nflpa can strike and remember we talked
about this yesterday the nflpa has a
leverage on the financial side not as
much on the health and safety side but
they got a lot of leverage on the
financial side and hopefully the two
sides can come to an agreement that the
owners will accept that the nflpa will
accept and then they can move forward
dealing with the bigger problem
of ensuring that they can get a season
in given everything that's happening
with the current pandemic but friday is
the day it's all pointing in the
direction it's a deadline driven
business nobody's going to move to their
bottom line prematurely that's why we
always talk about how important
deadlines are yeah they started talking
monday and they talked again today but
you don't start creeping toward what
your drop dead position is until the
clock begins to toll until you know that
the deadline has arrived and then you
get it done then and hopefully they'll
get something done that everyone can
live with and that will be practical and
that ultimately will be successful at a
time when the virus continues to spread
unchecked
and who knows if football is going to
happen at all this year at any level
high school probably not college at this
point probably not
nfl you know
there will be some regret
at some point they won't admit it but
there'll be some regret that they didn't
do the bubble approach now the bubble
approach would have been expensive the
bubble approach would have been
complicated it may have been unwieldy it
may have been impossible to put everyone
in there for five to six months that
many people that many fields that many
facilities and keep the virus out but
when you consider what's going on in the
cities where multiple teams are located
and in the country at large
i think they're gonna wish they had done
a bubble because i think the sports that
do the bubble are gonna find themselves
much more successful you don't keep the
virus out completely
but i think the teams that are playing
in cities like houston and dallas and
phoenix and la they're gonna have to
worry about outbreaks unless they can
get testing that is done daily if not
more frequently and with a turnaround
faster than 24 hours when you consider
the soaring demand for testing in these
cities that have become hot spots it's
just hard to reconcile football players
and teams coaches everyone who would
need tests getting it turned around that
fast when other people need results as
well and they're having to wait up to a
full week to get there so bottom line is
let's hope it all gets worked out
between the league and the union for now
and then let's hope they find a way to
successfully launch a season uh given
how frankly selfish and or stupid so
many americans have been when it comes
to the question of doing what needs to
be done to have a football season you
know if we don't have a football season
quick editorial comment i mean this
whole thing's editorial comments but but
an even more editorial comment on the
state of our country right now the
people who will be complaining the most
about no football are the people who are
will be most to blame for the fact that
there is no football and surely they
won't be accepting the blame for no
football even though it's their own
selfish and stupid behavior that put us
in a position where if football does
collapse it's going to be because of the
folks who end up complaining about it
the most all right there was a story
this morning out of louisville kenny
stills the texans receiver who had been
very involved in social justice
activities over the course of the past
several years he was involved in a
protest
for
uh the murder of brianna taylor from
several months ago still no arrests made
she was shot and killed in the execution
of a no knock warrant
and
that has been one of the flash points
nationwide as people are seeking justice
and equality for all americans kenny
stills and 87 others arrested on felony
charges and it's a very vague
intimidation of someone involved in a
legal process it seems like something
that's not going to stick it just seems
like somebody decided to be overly
aggressive with kenny stills and others
and of course the great irony is these
individuals who are protesting have
spent more time in jail than the police
officers who killed brianna taylor and
kenny stills unrepentant people have
asked me about the personal conduct
policy how will reply here well
if there's ultimately some sort of
conviction or guilty plea or no contest
plea than the nfl would look at it but
surely the nfl considers the broader
circumstances and the personal conduct
policy continues to be if nothing else a
pr tool the last thing you're going to
see the nfl do is suspend kenny spills
for six games because of whatever it is
that may come out of these charges that
have been lodged against him in
louisville it's still too early to know
exactly what happened or where it goes
from here but the point is this is far
different from the typical type of
criminal charge that we see nfl players
face and there's a chance it all goes
away sooner rather than later and it's
just an example of someone being overly
aggressive with people who are
exercising their right to protest the
murder of brianna taylor and the fact
that no one has been held accountable
for it yet all right last point before
we go there's plenty of buzz about a
story that is expected thursday in the
washington post regarding the washington
nfl franchise and there has been noise
about this there have been rumblings
about this for the past couple of weeks
i've heard some of the things that it
may be about
i'm not going to go down that rabbit
hole for now though i'm content to wait
as you should be as well there have been
tweets from people who currently cover
the team people who used to cover the
team suggesting it is not going to be
good for the franchise jason lochen for
who was with the post before he went to
nfl network and now he's at cbs he said
that the toxic culture of the team is
about to be exposed again so we'll see
we'll see what it is but i will say this
i first caught wind
of this effort
to
expose something
regarding the washington franchise a
week and a half ago and that's what
caused me within the process of making a
few phone calls to learn that dwight
shar
and fred smith two of the limited
partners
in the ownership of the team have been
trying to sell and are unhappy being in
partnership with daniel snyder and want
out
so
look
too far down the speculation path here
we had an item about this a week and a
half ago
um the bottom line is
something is coming out and i'm just
gonna leave it at that unless the
washington post decides to stand down
they've got their teeth into something
and uh we'll see what it is larry
michael the long-term play-by-play voice
of the franchise retired today out of
the blue a lot of people are looking at
the timing and saying well this is one
day before this story comes out if there
may be something there and again nobody
knows at this point it'll all become
clear when the story is published
assuming it is published
but uh something is out there and
something is percolating and i'm getting
the feeling if the washington post
doesn't run with it someone else
eventually will so stay tuned we may
have more to say about it tomorrow if
that post story finally is published
if not as i said
there's just enough smoke out there that
someone is going to like the match at
some point and we'll see what happens
with the washington franchise at a time
when it's in the process of trying to
change its name and logo on an expedited
basis that's it for wednesday's pft pm
quick reminder we're back on nbcsn
monday morning 7 a.m eastern to 9 a.m
with chris sims as we begin the process
of getting you ready for football season
or not let's hope it's not or not let's
hope it is football season but either
way pro footballtalk.com pftpm pft live
just some of the ways that you can keep
up to date on everything happening in
the national football league have a
great evening and we will do this again
tomorrow
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports